starting this hour off is Andrew hi
Andrew and welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hey thanks so much for having me
today I appreciate it
sure what's up so I've been a follower
of your methods for quite some time
paid off about thirty thousand dollars
in debt nearly seven years ago following
beans and rice rice and beans been on a
budget ever since elements are wise in
financing my money I've got a forty one
thousand dollars in the bank but that's
another call for another day the reason
I'm calling today was my girlfriend that
I about four months ago had taken
position in New York City and she is
from a different part of the country and
I basically said you know we're going to
make this sort of work and last we've
got to consider for a part it's not
going to work you got to come with me or
it's just not going to happen so we
moved in together back in January and
she's been on board with budget she's
actually taking their class many years
ago and unfortunately my occupation will
require me to take off for another
couple months here and so the other day
were sitting down going over our budget
together and we combined our budget from
the very beginning she makes about
35,000 a year I make 48 and she had
alluded to in the past that she had some
debt sort of looming was very very
apprehensive about talking about it
because a previous relationship ended
when when she apprised her her partner
of the fact that she had this then so
it's sort of just built some trust and
it came out the other day and I learned
that she has a hundred and thirteen
thousand dollars in student loan debt
doing this is in addition to a some debt
that I was already aware of $13,000 per
car note and an additional 11 thousand
for another student loan as I mentioned
she makes 35 a year I make 48 and it was
it wasn't low it was a I'm accustomed to
paying out that I'm accustomed to living
under my knees or not beyond my means
and one hundred and thirty six thousand
dollars is very very large some and some
of I'm looking for some advice
personally and I'm also looking at
personal advice for her
it's
it's it's clearly affected her and my
heart is telling me you know this is a
girl that could spend the rest of my
life with and my logical part of my
brain is saying you know Justin this is
a lot to wade into particularly
considering that so many marriages end
in failure because of financial reasons
so I figured I'd give you a call in the
third time those hit psychologists in
about seven years since I have so the
last nodes are debt-free following me
I'm coming back okay well how old are
you guys I'm 33 and she's 28 well to
start with um let's lay some baselines
if you're not married to someone well
you're not married to them and so you're
not responsible for their debt and you
should not be combining finances and
paying off debt with someone you're not
married to sure that's going to end
poorly
and so you're trying to play house and
you're not married and it doesn't work
it sets you up for all kinds of
relational and legal problems later on
and and it creates a bind because you're
if you begin to pay off this debt for
someone you're not married to her debt
that meaning then that that does start
to put a strain on the relationship now
let's let's fast-forward and take that
off the table for a minute and pretend
that you guys decided to get married and
yet were and you were married and or you
wanted to consider marriage getting
given this set of facts now if you were
to marry in the end of this or then the
question is or should you marry into
this I think someone that's willing to
sacrifice to pay off the debt and
willing to live on beans and rice and
willing to work hand in glove with their
spouse on his marriage material
if you're if you're a rough and so I
would not say to abandon a relationship
based on the fact that she's got debt I
would abandon it in a heartbeat if she's
not serious about getting rid of the
debt and she's not willing to sacrifice
and not willing say well I got a you
know I have to have my nails done I got
to have cable
I've got a hundred I've got a hundred
and eighteen thousand dollars in debt
and I make thirty five thousand dollars
a year right
this chick is known as clueless and you
gonna have a long life if you're married
to her if that's I think I can I can
tell you I'll tell you we've been on a
budget from the day one even since we
came before she came here with me I said
we're gonna get off of it and we've
we've lived in New York City very very
majorly oh yeah you have to live on what
you're just to live on what you're
making much less yes you're completely
on board with that well I think if
you're all are willing to fight if
you're willing to fight together and
willing to sacrifice together then you
you could start paying on this debt
after you're married and I would be just
fine with it I personally would not
abandon a relationship based on the fact
that somebody screwed up and went into
debt and I would abandon it if they're
not willing to do what it takes to get
out of that even even with the length I
mean we're looking at like 2027
according to you well you know the Money
Makeover TAC you know you did there was
a linear calculation you did not include
the fact that your incomes might go up
sure or that you might move to another
area of the country and your expenses go
down that's a good point as well and so
that there's you know you know you're I
can tell you this about your life it's
going to change yeah that was a sight
for one night so so you know you the
point is you're Sharron and I have faced
things that we didn't even know existed
since we've been married
yeah and so you're going to do the same
thing good and bad opportunities and
blessings curses and challenges that you
didn't even use no coming do you have
any encouragement for Emmys at this
point she's pretty distraught by the
fact she she'd love me to listen this is
I think the first encouraging word that
you can give her is that this doesn't
cost her this relationship okay I think
that's gonna she's already lost one over
this yeah and I think she's going to be
dramatically encouraged that she has a
teammate that's willing to stick with
her and fight this forward but you know
it you're kind of standing one foot on
your boat one on the dock though dude as
long as you're not married no you're
absolutely right so they got it you got
to think that through from a from a
practical standpoint I mean obviously as
a Christian there's a spiritual angle on
that for me as well but um but you've
got to decide that from a practical and
a legal standpoint it just doesn't work
well playing house very few people pull
it off I've tried to counsel people that
are playing house and for years and they
just because you don't know you don't
have that extra level of commitment well
we're committed yeah I know you are
right even married people aren't always
committed but at least you got a shot on
it then so that's there's a practical
aspect to it and so I think if you end
this relationship it should be for other
reasons other than finding out about her
debt and if you're going to go forward
on the relationship and be married is
the only time you should pay on it good
question sir it's honor to talk to you
you sound like a good young man
you